[Music]
[Applause]
gabe bonehead of the week
i was very surprised i was very
surprised by this vote uh we see the
twitter vote here
uh herschel walker won the twitter vote
he won the twitter vote however however
he did not win the youtube vote as a
result right we have maybe a different
bonehead we have a different
i'm not trying to give it away but this
was surprising to me because it was very
close the the the percentage difference
i won't say who won
but the percentage different was 2.2
percent right and we're not trying to
rig the vote here or anything we go by
the numbers first people wanted youtube
to throw it into the mix and now we have
an eclectic diverse almost like we have
two states two states
two two electors here that we're working
with uh with the popular vote in mind
because here's the thing folks you guys
vote every single week go to twitter at
tonymichaelspod or you can vote here on
youtube do not forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel because you can vote
in both places for bonehead of the week
every single week and then we break it
down right here on bone of the week for
you
but today was a little strange because
one one one place and the other one the
other place and
we had to certify the vote gabe i i know
we had to certify you know luckily you
know i did have to kind of fend off
my my home you know from uh from a bunch
of people who were unwilling to really
accept the results of this oh so it is
there might have been an insurrection
there almost
why are you receiving i got a call from
i see from dan quayle and he said
you know how to spell coup
and then he spelled it for me did he
spell it wrong did he spell it c-o-o-p
at first he was like c
yeah oh
you
he got it he got it by the end there he
finally he finally spelled q right
everyone knows that dan guell is famous
for not being able to spell potato
potato
and that's the guy who may have saved
democracy um speaking of people who
didn't try to save democracy uh here we
have who tried to overthrow democracy
here we have a couple people because
herschel walker would love to be part of
the next overthrow oh yeah he's trying
his best i mean i wouldn't
this guy already begins to throw in the
idea that this thing was rigged this
election in georgia isn't going to go my
way so i might as well pull a trump and
say guys the only way that i lose is if
the other guys cheat
yeah herschel what do you think he's
that smart though i don't know no i mean
he's going to talk about an organization
of men that's watching women that's
watching votes
what tick tock you know is that a
government agency he said he said it
it's a real thing he said there's a
government agency that of men watching
women
people take
these people seriously it's
i don't know they drank the kool-aid man
and they you know they took out another
mortgage on their home and they paid in
to the trump election fund and then they
found out that it was not a real thing
and they all got scammed and they said
hey
where do i sell my car to get cash
to give you more money trumpy baby
walker a guy who lives in texas who's a
carpetbagger who didn't graduate from
uga who was not in the fbi who did not
invent the wheel and did not invent the
internet um but he did he did herschel
walker invented
c t e oh well that's positive or at
least he first discovered it right right
that could be that could be well he's
probably a doctor too and speaking of
fake doctors we have senator rand paul
on the list as well um senator rand paul
of course we know trends every now and
then because he's a dumb [ __ ] yeah um
and yesterday was
no no surprise that he was trending
um
we me and you watched the video because
he started to trend we were like we're
like who's the bone end of the week we
were trying to figure this out and they
were like oh of course he did something
right rand paul was trending and what
the funniest part is is gabe asked me
before we went before we went and seen
exactly why he was trending he said why
is ram vulturing i said i don't know
probably something some stupid [ __ ] he
said to fouchy and i mean
you can't you can guess exactly
at this point it's now always going to
be about fouchy like if they're ever
what
if there ever was a story of two
villains or like two rivals right and
it's like what's your villain origin
story and rand paul's like as soon as
fouchy was born i knew there was a
disruptance in the in in
in in the earth and i had to go against
him and now his whole thing is he go you
know he's like i'm a doctor and he tries
to go and dance about you at any point
he tries to go back an actual dog you
know it's funny in this clip here
because rand paul and and all the
[ __ ] the fouchy obsessed right wing
far right people who think he's some
kind of i don't know what the hell they
think he is some i i just can't figure
it out some kind of demon or some [ __ ]
but he he's accusing dr fauci of of
owning um uh uh patents right which he
does because he he is he is a doctor and
he does work in a lab and he does
develop things for medicine
that end up being patents for different
medicine and things and that's how that
works right
and generally if you have a patent you
might or might not get paid for it
depends on the situation yeah and
sometimes it could be a [ __ ] load of
money right we know there's a [ __ ] it
also depends on how many people are on
the patent so that's right yeah you
could be like one person or it could be
a team of people right it could be
dozens and dozens of people that
actually quote unquote own this patent
because you're getting royalties like
you would in any other thing now here
senator rand paul in this clip is asking
for some proof
and he and he really steps in here when
dr fauci
like gives him the yeah just watch just
watch jesus christ all the distribution
of money in research grants
um well first of all let's talk about
roy that's the question no that's the
question have you ever overseen him
won't even let him answer if what do you
let him talk and the reason why
rand paul won't like dr founty talk is
because he's going to hand him his ass
right i mean that's the reason why rand
paul knows the gig here rand paul knows
he's lying he knows he's exaggerating
[ __ ] because yes dr fauci does make
money and patents he does
and he makes money in research that's
what he does
that's part of his work that he does
but it it is it is disingenuous for rand
paul to say anything anymore about dr
falchi like anything at all right is
disingenuous never received a royalty
payment from a company yeah that you
later oversaw money going to that
company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it
well here's the thing is why don't you
let us know
gotcha
how much you've gotten ha ha i mean dr
fought he's like do you have any idea
how many because he probably is on like
you said teams for those patents you're
probably in a lab of people right and
he's probably on hundreds of them right
yeah and there's some that he's probably
on that he's not even really fully aware
of like it's an old patent and he he
really didn't have a lot of research
work to do with it but because he had
something to do with it he's placed on
that patent right yep and and somehow
somehow rand paul thinks because dr
fauci had
my new thing to do with some patent
somewhere that's making no money because
that's something that that [ __ ]
fouchy's gonna show you here is that
yeah yeah you're talking about money
okay we'll show you how much money but
again they're making
they're making they're trying to make
mountains out of out of molehills here
right let's let's listen and from what
entities the nih refuses look we ask
them we ask them the nih we asked them
whether or not who got it and how much
they refused to tell us they sent it
redacted here's what i want to know it's
not just about you everybody on the
vaccine committee have any of them ever
receive money from the people who make
vaccines can you tell me that can you
tell me if anybody on the vaccine
approval committee did you let him
[ __ ] talk
questions
sound bite number one are you gonna let
me answer a question
this is great let me give you some
information first of all
according to the regulations people who
receive royalties are not required to
divulge them even on their financial
statement according to the buy doll act
so let me give you some example
from
2015
to 2020
i the only warranties i have
was my lab and i made a monoclonal
antibody for use in vitro reagent that
had nothing to do with patients
and during that period of time now wait
for it because he's going to tell you
how much money he made everyone get
ready to know how rich
how rich dr fauci is from this patent
hold on to your seat here you're going
to find out
my royalties range from 21 a year
to 17 700 a year and the average per
year here we go was 191.46
cents
he's really rolling in it you know it
would almost be like it would almost be
like rand paul who takes money from a
lot of [ __ ] people even makes money
selling stock and buying stock during
the pandemic or like maybe makes money
from russia
right right all kinds of [ __ ] you think
this guy would be like whoa 152 bucks
some [ __ ] you could buy a steak dinner
with that this guy yeah i mean that is
it's honestly like oh what can we buy
with this he's like well look look we
can go all out and they're like oh my
god what can we buy and he's like a a
very nice dinner right you know he's
like wait wait wait you're not making
thousands not making millions he's like
no actually you know i'm making as
little as 21 dollars
a year that's not not like a minute not
like every second a year you're like
that's like a couple sandwiches worth
and it's like i mean you can maybe get
three if you go to subway you know right
this is ridiculous
the best part of this video is to come
though
it's all red it's all redacted and you
can't get any information on the 1800
scientists your time is so we want to
know whether or not people got money
from the people who made the manual
senator paul your time is long over
expired i gave you an additional two and
a half minutes the witness has responded
we are going to move on so i i actually
missed it in here let's let's see this
best we asked him this is not the clip
that we saw yesterday whether or not it
isn't
no because when he says sound bite
number one it's on fouchy but he says it
here and it's still on ran it's still on
paul oh i see i see he's gotta find
where that clip was yeah i know because
he calls him senator soundbite doesn't
he and nobody calls it well he goes no
because he goes sound bite number one
he might well he might have been like
senator and then he said sound bite and
he goes i sure he was calling it out and
you're like this shit's gonna be used
against me sound bite number one
can you let me answer the question i
swore he called him senator soundbite
here's another
from a company that you later oversaw
money going to that company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it well now here's the thing is
why don't you let us know why don't you
reveal how much you've gotten and from
what entities the nih refuses look we
ask them we ask them the nih we asked
them whether or not who got it and how
much they refused to tell us they sent
it redacted here's what i want to know
it's not just about you everybody on the
vaccine committee have any of them ever
receive money from the people who make
vaccines can you tell me that can you
tell me if anybody on the vaccine
approval committees ever received any
money from people's questions
sound bite number one are you gonna let
me answer a question there it is sound
bite number one i thought he called i
know he was just trying to get like
senator you're gonna let me finish and
then he was like sound bite number one
because that's totally what he is and
totally i mean like that's i mean here's
the thing you look at like one is what
was the committee hearing for what was
the hearing for and what was he
answering questions about and like was
the questions that he had
even remotely related to what was
happening and even if it was
he's already answered the question and
already told him i make [ __ ] 21 at
the low end 700 on the high end and on
average i'm making
120-150 bucks or whatever it was right
enough to
buy
some nice
meal maybe if that's like not even
covering the tip and that's like a meal
for one like if i were to go to like the
the capitol club
and go buy a meal like that would
probably be the lunch oh my god
i i would imagine that uh the way that
ran senator soundbyte rand paul
does his hair it probably cost about 125
bucks oh dude i would say
are not are not charm has got to be at
least 150 perm man yeah i mean you can't
get it wet you know i i i learned most
of what i know about perms from legally
blonde so you know okay i am an expert i
would say that's good that's good
senator soundbyte from inch forth
henceforth
will be known here on the tony michaels
podcast but you could also say all of
the republican representatives and like
congressmen and senators or senator or
like you know congressman or
representative sound bite senator sound
bite like that's what they are because
that's what they're doing they're just
trying to create fake outrage and
they're trying to say hey i need my
sound my 15 minutes of
of spotlight or fame on newsmax or oan
or fox news or whatever [ __ ] network
because i want to be like gotcha [ __ ]
and really it's like no you didn't you
didn't get him well let's talk about a
gotcha [ __ ] moment um for someone who
wants to be a senator sound bite
herschel walker ooh
you i i questioned yesterday you were
like no we need to put herschel walker
on yeah and i was like father's day is
this sunday what's the what's the what's
why why would we put hershel walker do
you have a clip that we could play or
something that i could show you so why
why we're putting him on the list
because i was really unaware of this i
have been paying attention to our
hearing and some of the production now
everyone knows
that gabe
is
christian walker herschel walker's uh
son that he actually acknowledges that
is his son apparently
um he's his virtual roommate on the
internet um not actual roommate but you
know kind of parody type right right
yeah on the internet and they're they're
maybe based on a video we're about to
play there may be a video coming out
where i'm just trying to talk to my
roommate you know because you know
father's day is on sunday it is it is on
sunday a lot of people in the beginning
of the show or said they're going to
celebrate father's day and june teens on
because it's a duel it's a dual day um
right there but uh but what video are
you going gonna show us here what is
this um so this is a video that was
released uh let's let me look up really
quick when the actual release date of
this video was this is christian walker
right do i have to play the whole 50
seconds of this uh your roommate here
just the [ __ ] you don't
you don't have to play the whole okay
because i really this i mean you could
play the whole thing but you don't have
to play the whole thing your roommate is
really he's he's a piece of [ __ ] work
this is um definitely a character yeah
but this video i don't want to lose the
audience by playing now i know i know
but you're going to make a video based
on i'm going to make a video that might
be more kind of um
digestible okay so so everyone it's five
527 is when he released
that video wait wait wait this year yeah
yeah this is this year so this is 5 27
this is within the last month
one two three uh yeah like three and a
half weeks ago oh okay so it sounds like
he knew news was coming maybe
maybe he's definitely doing high
projection here but on on this take it's
something
let's let's watch it here and see what
we got fathers it would be great if you
stayed home and raised your kids instead
of ran off to bang a bunch of women who
weren't your baby mama stay home and
raise your freaking kids your kids need
a father get back home get back home if
you take out your thing and you get a
woman pregnant guess what the party days
are over the acting foolish days are
over you go get a freaking job and you
support your new
family get home
okay okay okay okay
the reason the reason why the reason why
this this is um i guess newsworthy that
this [ __ ] chucklehead is yelling and
screaming the same thing over and over
and number one he's talking about he's
alluding to abortions i think here yeah
he's yeah he's talking about abortions
and he's talking about how uh but the
funny part is is with the recent news i
think that's what you're good yeah yeah
yeah so if we go back
earlier this week right i believe it was
that's like centuries ago gabe that's
like i know i know i think i want to say
it was tuesday maybe okay wednesday
maybe maybe was there only one baby
revealed because we knew that it was
tony tony if there's one there's more
you find out that he has uh a secret
ten-year-old uh child who who christian
marshall no hershey herschel
has a sibling is what you're saying yeah
yeah he's got a sibling now whether he
knew about that sibling or not i don't
know it seems a little bit weird that he
would make a video like that if he
actually didn't know about it but then
again i wouldn't be surprised if he did
know about it and then maybe that's when
he found out maybe that's exactly i know
here's the thing as much as herschel
walker says i love my son i love my son
i mean hershel walker's also on his
which one which one
the son yeah well he's like i love my
one son
christian walker he says he said he
claimed before this is on what he's
claimed before and talked about now the
other thing to remember here is that
christian walker
is gay yeah but hershel walker has also
talked about he doesn't really support
the gay community or the right to get
married
so these are things that contradict the
beliefs that his own son has which is
very hypocritical or which it just
doesn't feel right for someone that's it
doesn't even walkers say really really
some vile stuff about about people who
are in the lgbtq community
he calls them all he says they're
liberal trash and he calls them ghetto
ghetto liberals and he says uh blue hair
you know blue hair liberal girl and all
this [ __ ] and there's like oh and
then he obviously he's very transphobic
he does not support trans people doesn't
support them being involved in sports
which again is like point zero
something percent in terms of what the
actual breakdown of people who
may have been male and transition to
female and then participate in a
female-led sport right and so it's a lot
of people projecting their own
insecurities and their own kind of
worries on to other people and worrying
about their own lives which is very on
brand for republicans right which is
like let me enter your home and tell you
how to live your life especially a
social media influencing republicans
exactly who that's all they do is spout
hate so let's get back to herschel
walker so we found out he had one
unknown child we found out he had one
news one unknown child and then
and then it was revealed
that he had additional
unknown children that were secrets how
many how many and i believe the numbers
at three right now
[Laughter]
should you should we start making a
graph like a thermometer where you i
only fill up the thermometer of how many
uh unknown children yeah yeah
yeah so it's got to be a lot because
christian walker was saying it over and
over again right
every time he said you know right maybe
baby mama whatever but the other thing
is really important is because herschel
walker has commented and said that the
issues that happen within our society
are based on fatherless homes so he's
attacked people who are fatherless
and he's made home's father and he's
made homes
that's fatherless which again is
completely on brand with the republican
party
and be hypocrites but what happened was
wednesday secret child was revealed you
know name anonymous obviously and the
mother anonymous which good and then we
find out on thursday that two more
unknown children have been added to the
herschel walker secret kids club this
this isn't like these are young children
too right these are really yeah i mean
this is recent
the one one of which is ten christian
walker is 22.
uh
the third one is 13.
and
it looks like he has another
different these are different women or
these are it looks like different women
so you've got one woman who had a boy
who's 10. then you had another person
who had a child who's 13
out of 1
you know i don't know yeah yeah i'm not
yeah yeah and i'm just you end up if you
having different partners and you end up
having different children you know
i just i just think it goes back to the
hypocrisy of it all you say these shitty
things and your roommate says these
shitty things [ __ ] these
and the other one is a 20 year old
daughter so he's got three sons and one
daughter but christian up until this
week is the only one that well that's
the only one that everyone acknowledged
and that's the only one that he
acknowledged and that's the one you know
and the other the other thing too is
that the party with their you know his
campaign you know his team was like oh
we've never not acknowledged his other
children he loves them all the same
don't try to politicize this and it's
like it's a bit of an issue if you've
never actually acknowledged them and
then the day that they come out in terms
of being revealed that they were secret
children out of wedlock then you're like
i i love all my children all the same
and that's how it was for the first kid
and then two additional kids came out
yeah maybe maybe maybe there's something
we just don't know about herschel walker
maybe he invented cloning and these are
clones children i'm just saying i mean
you know what was it golly the sheep
right yep yeah well
maybe he was that maybe not only he was
the inventor but he was the inventor of
cloning and he was the winner actually
the wheel he invented the internal
combustion engine um
which which i don't know
past walker here because uh
[ __ ] him i guess you would say he is a
bonehead but where's where's the um the
dm we got this uh dishonorable mention
ken paxton what was what was the reason
why he was on the list is there a
certain reason yeah as dm yeah i put him
as dm because ken paxton decided to give
his two cents
on the victims of ivaldi that's where he
said god or some [ __ ] he said god has a
plan and you know life is short and
it is what it is which again very on
brand for republicans to be like we care
about republican we care about lives and
then only to say yeah well you know it's
god's plan like this isn't like this
isn't like some [ __ ] drake song okay
this is actual these are actual people
actual children
that have lives that matter but to him
he's talking about the uvaldi deaths and
specifically salon has a quote here of
texas attorney general kim paxton who is
uh
increment uh being investigated on
criminal charges on the utility death
god has a plan shannon watts tweeted
texas your current attorney general
thinks the answer to mass shootings is
god has a plan and armed teachers
if you want an actual plan to address
uh gun violence please uh
follow and support raquel uh garza is
that is that are they running
um oh yeah she is she is running i don't
know is she running uh she's running for
attorney general in in texas um is what
shannon is pointing out here so um yeah
he said god has a plan you know what i i
remember this because i tweeted
um i tweeted i think i tweeted at ken
paxton i believe i i don't know if he
posted something or something i think i
tweeted at him uh you can take your god
and stick it up your ass like if this is
if this is the god's plan that you had
you can take that and stick it up your
ass uh what's this link you sent me here
so that's the actual audio clip so if
you want to play that that's
that that is ken paxton
uh being a shitty human being okay well
let's play this and then we'll move on
to the alpha cause we gotta get to the
winner here yeah yeah uh let's see okay
so we again
do
let's let's pull this up and for anyone
who doesn't know ken paxton is the
attorney general for texas this is also
the guy that this is under video this is
just audio right it's a video but just
audio yeah yeah okay yeah we'll just
play it here listen
it might give a little comfort
look i think it's it's difficult to give
comfort if i lost one of my children i'd
be pretty devastated
uh especially in in a way that is so
senseless and you know seemingly has no
purpose
uh i think i would say i would just have
to if
i had the opportunity to talk to people
i'd have to say look there's always a
plan i believe god always has a plan
uh life is short no matter what oh my
goodness yeah certainly we're not gonna
make sense of
okay i can't i can't take any more of
that god has a plan god had a plan to
[ __ ] have this guy go in and right
god has a plan life is short like life
is yes life is very [ __ ] short
especially for children especially when
you're louder people go slaughter these
[ __ ] people because you want you want
anyone and everyone to own a gun because
a couple a couple of families in this
country benefit with probably
the the response again the response is
very on brand for republicans and the
gqp where they say i mean it is very
much they're like with that being said
they're like look i am devastated i
would hate if my children were the
victim of gun violence of course they
would now with that being said life is
short and we just got to move on
to the other kids
why do you guys complain that is what
they're saying that is what they're
they're upset at the fact that people
are upset that children were slaughtered
that's crazy i shouldn't um we got our
alpha cuck here um uh berry uh louder
milk we know why berry loudermilk is the
alpha cuck here he keeps lying about
this tour that he's giving gabe
at the camera he's changed his story so
many times it went from no tour to i
gave a tour to a few people then i gave
it to her to a few families and their
friends to i gave a tour to about 16
people okay and yeah they were taking
photos of some weird angles and
stairways and the other thing that the
other thing that because i heard an
interview where he's talking about
because the one guy standing in the
stairwell taking a picture of the stair
he's like oh well there's a railing
there that has a really ornamental thing
that he was taking no
you can tell he's taking a picture up
this night also [ __ ] banister there's
also a [ __ ] out of here
um it was
who was it it was
uh
it was uh representative zoe lofgren and
she said in an interview they were
asking i think it was on msnbc but
they're asking like oh what about this
claim that they were taking photo and
she's like no one ever takes a [ __ ]
photo of that thing like no that's not a
thing that you take photos of that's not
something that somebody comes in and
goes i'm going to the capitol and i'm
taking a photo of this gold
object
it's just it's just
they're just making up [ __ ] and the
thing is and then he's talked about the
children wanting to see the tram and all
this yeah like he just
because at first it was i didn't give
any tours right and then it was like no
no my family was there with me and then
he's like oh well maybe constituents and
then he's like no no no we didn't go
these places and he's like yeah we went
there because of like it just keeps
moving the goal post i mean it that he's
on brand for these republicans and i
didn't know this barry loudermilk nobody
did nobody knew who this guy was he
could have lived his life in just
mediocrity and no one would have ever
known what he was just a subpar white
dude mediocre
that's who he was
and then he decided to enter the chat
and say i never give a tour i never gave
a tour and then he was like okay maybe
maybe i did give a tour okay i was a
little bit naughty i did give a tour
okay you know what i did give a tour it
was to a group of people oh it's like
what do you want me to like bring not
bring people in before the insurrection
so they don't know how to get around
that would be very unchristian like
[Laughter]
oh my god speaking of people who wanted
to uh
overthrow our government we do have one
of those another one of those on our
bone of the week he's actually the
winner
john eastman we know is
a law professor some obscure guy no one
knew until he tried to commit treason
here at least that's what it looks like
this guy was trying to trying to
overthrow our government the united
states and trying to commit possible
violence when he's trying to get mike
pence to do something that mike pence
can't do
and then the violent mob because he was
at the ellipse that day
gabe everyone's like oh john eastman was
just the legal part of it i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was on the
stage and citing the [ __ ] people who
went to say hang mike pence and they
were calling him out and and bull [ __ ]
john eastman is part of the what created
the mob he wasn't just the guy writing
the [ __ ] memo that's all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] him and rudy
giuliani stood on the stage and said in
so many words we have a plan and we need
to execute this
i mean remember he was he was also at
the willard hotel the command center
right for the effort to deny biden in
his presidency rudy giuliani steve
bannon and christina bob they were all
there trying to coordinate this effort
to overthrow the government of the
united states and when pence told them
no they kept pressuring and kept
pressuring until the very last minute
and yes pence did not break he tried to
find a way to break where he wouldn't be
criminally liable but speaking of crime
um and other officials it seems as if um
well why is that staying there anyways
now let's let's go into the tweet here
there we go there we go uh tristan
schnell has here breaking genie thomas
officially served with the letter
requesting her to meet with january 6
committee regarding her communications
with john eastman um they are proposing
july 6 7 8 or the week of the 11th um so
in july
so this is june 16th this is yesterday
that they served our sent i guess uh
jeannie thomas clarence thomas the
supreme court justices wipe a letter
saying we want you to come talk to us
about the information in the john
eastman emails that's really funny
do you remember 2016 there was a
presidential election
and there were a lot of people talking
about someone's emails do you remember
this yeah who's the woman i can't
remember the email lady that we had but
they still talk about her over on fox
yeah
didn't she go through like 11 hours of
like yeah she did testimony hearings she
did she did go through a lot of hours of
testimony um i can't remember it's
hillary clinton
right but here we actually have an email
lady who's actually trying to overthrow
the government with john eastman now
john eastman still tweets did you know
this i didn't know this still this
morning john eastman still tweets here
it is here's his twitter account i'm not
[ __ ] you
this is dr john eastman's twitter
account no don't call him doctor don't
but that's what it says i'm just well
you know what you know i could say a lot
of things on the internet and it
wouldn't be true that the greatest part
here is former former constitutional law
professor he isn't any
more was the dean at chapman university
too i don't know where the hell i think
that's somewhere in california or
something i'd be curious to know how
many people come out of that school
being like oh man i got the best
education on this guy or being like oh
my god please don't ask me about john
eastman please don't ask me about johnny
right like
there's completely embarrassing like
this guy tried to [ __ ] overthrow the
government not only does he have a
twitter he has a sub stack where he
apparently writes about his crimes omg
mrs thomas asked me to give me an update
about election what's the crime here
guys i tried to [ __ ] do a coup okay
what's the big deal this is hilarious
this is hilarious the guy who tried to
overthrow the government with trump
actually in all caps tweets omg he's
supposed to be some kind of
constitutional professor and smart dude
right
omg miss thomas here he's deflecting
here again they're gonna keep doing this
stuff they just can't stop you we seen
yesterday this guy constantly i mean he
was saying fifth before they would
finish a question right did you notice
that in some like at first he was like
uh i have to believe that
but like before they finish the
questions like fifth fifth it kind of
reminds me of that scene from dave
chappelle's show when he's like one two
three four fifth i believe the fifth
yeah uh
it also reminds me of um
of trump
right i mean
this was over a hundred times
eastman said i plead the fifth yeah i
mean that's trump did it over 500 times
that's it well
he's five times is better at the fifth
yeah fifth he's fifth better than the
fifth then johnny i don't know this
these guys these guys like jim jordan's
like i we didn't learn anything
yesterday because john eastman pled the
fifth 100 times that's why we didn't
learn anything new that was a good thing
but i mean here john eastman is can't
stop talking about this right
he is he is now placing more evidence on
himself by tweeting this
mrs thomas asked me to give an update
about election litigation to her group
stop the presses like
dude stop talking your way into charges
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you are criminally exposed because if
you pled fifth in the [ __ ] testimony
what and this is the same thing like you
did a you know what was that or navarro
it's kind of the same thing
stop talking stop these people keep
opening their mouths and giving out the
details of what they did and then they
say we did nothing wrong why do people
keep coming after us no i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna you know follow the
subpoena no i'm not gonna tell you i'm
not going to tell you under oath what we
did but i am willing to tell ari
melbourne what we did on tv right
but also by the way if you guys can just
buy my book because that's my legal
defense fund and it's going to go
anywhere from a couple hundred to 300 to
500 to a million dollars for a legal
team but i also want to represent myself
because i don't want to spend that much
money
like for a guy that
you know navarro exactly or specifically
like for a guy that wants to say
he's innocent
he's unwilling to give over the
documents to talk about
uh what he did or rather talk about what
he didn't do if he's so innocent
and then say
i'm gonna take the cheap route here i'm
gonna i'm gonna represent myself but i'm
gonna ask you for money
to pay for a lawyer but i'm not actually
gonna pay for so it's very like trump
right like help me with this fund i need
to defend myself but i'm not actually
gonna use the money for what i said i
was gonna use it for
well here is here's a little bit of the
uh hearing and the coverage that we did
yesterday on the hearing again everyone
go follow on midas touch youtube channel
we'll be doing the hearings next week
now those links will be coming out soon
so make sure to set reminders for those
but here's some of the footage from
yesterday's hearing of our coverage of
john eastman plea
pleading the fifth just a few days later
dr eastman emailed rudy giuliani and
requested that he be included on a list
of potential recipients of a
presidential pardon because that's the
news that we got is that he was pimping
for a pardon here on an email and then
here is dr eastman pleading the fifth so
did the trump legal team ask you to
prepare a memorandum regarding the vice
president's role in the accounting of
electoral votes to join session of
congress on january 6 2022.
dr eastman before they finish the
question united states the vice
president could reject a lecture from
seven states and declare that the
president had been realized
like he knows where the questions are
going right and he goes
that's going to be a crime that's going
to be a crime that's going to be a crime
because that's the thing here is he's
swinging fit to not self-incriminate
himself yeah is what he's doing it's
crazy
the first sentence of the memo
starts off by saying seven states have
transmitted dual slate's electors to the
president of the senate
is that statement in this memo true
even his lawyer here look at look at him
holding up shut the [ __ ] up stop talking
why did you why did you say you were
going to show up to this oh my god damn
it now i'm [ __ ] it only it only gives
us
more
it
a hundred times
john eastman would have
self-incriminated and that's how we have
to look at this at this point because he
was looking for a pardon
even after january 6 so john eastman is
our winner for bow net of the week folks
let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
john eastman end of the week what a
patriot i mean patriot i mean what a
loser
i plead the fifth okay so everybody if
you want to participate in bone in the
week go follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod every single week there
is a poll there for bone end of the week
also subscribe to the youtube channel
the tony michaels podcast the poll will
be there as well you never know what's
going to happen in our elections gay
because we
we do not rig these elections no you
vote you decide we break it down for
bone end of the week stick around right
after the music we'll have some messages
[Music]
[Applause]